foreign
we haven't talked about what's happening
to gen Z we haven't talked about what's
happening to kids
you know I talked about them before in a
sort of negative way like gen Z shows up
on campus and then all of a sudden
there's all these problems but but again
I don't get angry I'm not moralistic we
have to understand
what's happening to gen Z so I just want
to talk if I can just talk a little bit
about that and could you also Define gen
Z
yeah and then please continue so
Millennials are those who were born in
1982 and we used to think that it would
go to maybe 2 000. but it turns out that
kids were born in 1996 and later are
different from those born say 1994 and
earlier I mean it's a surprisingly sharp
cut equivalent to what we find with
birth year in 1946 you know the post-war
world really was different to grow up in
and I believe so I'm drawing on work by
Gene twangy but I've also added she and
I are working together and I've added a
lot
what happened is that if you were born
in say 1990
you didn't get you couldn't you didn't
get an iPhone until maybe around 2009 is
when teenager at 10 is when teenagers
started getting it so if you're born in
1990 you didn't get an iPhone a
smartphone until you were 20.
and you didn't get on social media you
might have been on Facebook partly but
you don't live on social media until you
have your own smartphone
whereas if you're born in 1997
you are 13 in 2010 when you might get
your first smartphone and you might get
on Instagram
in 2012 when huge numbers did so I
believe gen Z is defined by the fact
that they got smartphones and social
media during early puberty there's a lot
of research pointing to early puberty
around 11 to 13 for girls 12 to 15 for
boys
what's coming into your brain then is
really important because your your
frontal cortex is wiring itself up so
when human beings are raised without
much Independence but yes with a phone
and they spend their childhood just
interacting with the screen and
especially social media
I believe it it messes up cortical
development
the girls in particular the rates of
anxiety and depression are more than a
much more than 100 since 2010 the rate
of self-harm hospitalization for
self-harm is nearly tripled
for pre-teen girls
so gen Z is in big big trouble
they're hurting they're fragile they're
not doing well in the workplace managers
are finding them very hard to work with
so we have a generation that's running
off the rails and this is not a
moralistic thing like oh those kids
these days this is a compassionate thing
like these are our children like my kids
are 13 and 16. everyone either has kids
or is you know is has nieces and nephews
so this is I think the greatest
emergency we Face the greatest Health
Emergency I think for kids this is much
much bigger than covet covid was a big
deal for old people it wasn't a big deal
for children in terms of the risk but
this is you know a doubling more than
doubling of suicide rates for kids since
2010. so that's what I'm working on now
what decisions have you made
in your parenting that you feel have
been perhaps
most impactful less typical or the Venn
diagram of those two overlapping
so the terrible mental health of gen Z
is caused by two factors one is the vast
overprotection kids need to practice
independence self-governance from the
time they're seven or eight they need
Independence but they don't get it
anymore
you and I when we were growing up you're
younger than me but I presume you were
allowed to roam around your neighborhood
oh I was free range yeah riding bikes
everywhere when I was younger I was also
in a rural environment but yeah I was
out and about very early yeah so kids
must have free-range childhoods they
must Practice Independence and they had
that before the 90s and in the 90s
things got incredibly safe we locked up
the drunk drivers we took the perverts
off the street crime plummets but we
freaked out about child abduction
unnecessarily so in the 90s we stopped
letting kids out and this affects gen Z
in the late Millennials anyway but you
asked about me so what my wife and I did
we live in here in New York City
in Greenwich Village
we because we're friends with Lenora
scenesi who wrote this fantastic book
free-range kids
we let our kids out to play in
Washington Square Park we sent them out
on errands when they were eight nine
years old
you know New York City was very safe
back then it's a little more dangerous
now but it was very very safe in the
2010s and we sent them out and we had
them walk to school way you know a year
or two before before anyone else was
doing it so I'm very glad we did that
we also made it clear no social media at
least until High School absolutely none
in Middle School
then that's been very good when they
start sixth grade my kids tell me
everyone's on Instagram and we said no
you we're not going to let you do it
the one mistake I made was that when my
son wanted Fortnight in sixth grade
and we said no
because video games can be addictive
I but now that I've dug into the
literature a lot more now I see that yes
a lot of boys do get in trouble from
video games because they're on it so
much they're addicted to it and it
pushes out everything else but a couple
hours a day
for boys
to be in a group that's battling other
boys it turns out that's actually a good
thing and my son was somewhat cut off in
sixth grade good in what respects how is
that assessed just in terms of acting as
a release valve for aggression or social
cohesion group dynamics so the release
valve idea from Freud does not
to end up being true kids don't need to
blow off aggression it's not like that
it's rather that girls and boys each
need to practice their gendered
behaviors this is what play is play for
all mammals is a way you practice in
childhood the skills you'll need as an
adult and so boys and girls have very
different play boys tend to break up
into groups to compete with other groups
and multiplayer video games allow them
to do that so I'm not saying these are
great I'm saying
ideally the kid should be out having
Adventures but given that all the kids
are home they're not allowed out until
they're you know 11 12 years old
so at least a multiplayer video game
allows them to be part of a group now
it's not a very creative group the rules
are all set by the company so it's not
like video games are anywhere near as
good as being had on their own but
they're not bad
until it gets to be heavy so
that was a small mistake once covet hit
we did let him get fortnite and then
that was the only way he talked with his
friends
so that was okay the mistake the one
mistake I think we did make was we
didn't we tried a few different summer
camps we never quite found one but if we
I wish we'd found a really good summer
and I would urge this for everybody
who's a parent of young kids from the
time your kid is about eight or nine
certainly
I'd say eight find a Sleepaway Camp that
is pretty unstructured and unsupervised
the kids have to have a lot of
Independence you know some summer camps
now are sober protective you can't go to
the bathroom unless you have an escort
and sometimes you need two escorts
because what if one escort falls down
and gets hurt like it's crazy
overprotective everywhere but if you can
find a summer camp
that is not crazy or protective send
your kid there every summer that I think
is one of the few chances they really
have to develop skills to be out in the
woods so I wish we'd done that